we'll remember this as the last day of
the Republic I always try to help out
the law we don't really know anything in
the rest of the world it was my fault I
take full responsibility so let's have a
conversation how would you like to know
[Music]
[Music]
bill Weasley
[Music]
if it's the right filmmaker I'm willing
to do anything I'll do two lines or I'll
do the lead or I'll do something which
isn't flattering good filmmakers are the
reason that I'm an actor at all is
because I love good films so I think I'm
also just willing to throw myself into
whatever they need me to be for their
movie Caroline you mustn't let his
business get inside him the film is a
kind of a gothic ghost story
my character grew up very poor always
looked up to the upper classes wanted to
be from the upper classes it must be
some alternative was very long process
actually getting the accent I worked a
great dialect coach we kind of invented
a new accent for him because he was from
the working class and yet he aspires to
be from a higher class and yet he can't
lose the accent completely concerned
about his state of mind he so he kind of
invented that we also listened to Philip
Larkin reading his own poems I work all
day and get half drunk at night he grew
up not wealthy and yet when he read his
poems the accent he had was very posh
and there's something weird happens when
you realize that somebody has changed
themselves in some way through their
accent who do you think you're talking
to
[Music]
[Applause]
hooks is full-on fascist English
upper-class roles as ours some time and
it's very aspirational and strong Harry
who Weasley I thought I had done a
really good job with my accent on Harry
Potter until I turned up on set and went
Australian true enough oh the whale lane
a gray bank and couldn't stop being
Australian for a whole day my first day
in front of everybody so that was the
worst thing in the world what you want
to do is forget about it when you're
doing it and just be able to be the
character he always loved him more we're
leaving me behind I always try to help
out the law it's funny so they're an
American is definitely easier than a
more general American or something from
either coast the southern thing I don't
know I think because of the way that the
sentences work and the open down of the
tonality of it you can hear it you can
grab on to it it snacks you can grab on
to South African or Welsh like they're
the nightmare ones they're the ones that
you just like wake up sweating about
having to do someday we always win I
mean I didn't go to drama school or
anything like that so it's my own little
system which is developed but yeah a lot
of exercises in the mornings and I tend
to keep the accent up during the day
just so it settles into my mouth and I'm
not doing an accent when we start doing
a scene nothing like that
walk oftentimes I'll find a poem that I
think suits the character and that will
be my mantra that I go to because it
puts you in a good state of mind and it
gets your mouth in shape for what you're
about to do so my only function was to
be someone she could use to escape I
keep it up on set but then when they say
caught in the last take of the day I go
back to Irish and then I can go home and
talk to my friends and not have them
hate me you know so so I can try and
view myself again